Samson oh oh sure yeah that's a east of
the East enrichments out here for
airport kenka coughs mama swear I'll
rape me of Blair Barry nettleson mm-hmm
gallery from Virginia yeah all right and
we got speed tell us something about
this period in 1947 during the summer
when you came to see your father good
what did your father do in Roswell my
father was the sheriff of chance camp
and they lived in the courthouse the
jail in the sheriff's quarters were in
the same building and they lived on the
downstairs floor and then downstairs was
an office with two rooms and the
jail is upstairs prisoners were playing
in the office and then up the stairs to
and what words were you living with your
folks night you know I wasn't living
with them I was there visiting I my
husband and I were both students after
World War Two in Las Vegas
and
bathroom too
to finish up hard degrees which we get
started
our education had been interrupted by
World War two and so we in fact that I
sometimes did not go quite as much
because I had a young son and he liked
to stay with my mother and if I was busy
for school and we also a little business
and working in and so each day there and
probably get in there for a while or I
don't know whether that one time I was
actually in school
going back and forth staying up there
class
so you came your father at his office
one day in July we think yes I came I I
was reading the Buicks walk into his
office from the sheriff's porch and I
the paper came out with this and I
didn't read the paper what do you
remember about what the papers about the
headlines and
of my salsa and I don't remember what he
told me about it
but I hit what so interesting and I
think some way inside of me and I loved
it and I wanted it to be true and I
wanted to talk to him about it and
sometimes I went into the office
and he was getting all these home he had
I remember he came into the kitchen and
talked about in a bone I with the phone
calls and that he had just
talk about that because well the
distance at the times you know it's
faxing something they're sanding it
without distance now I world was a lot
bigger but he has it was so and so you
know another thing that world and world
war they had really revealed things that
we all think had been revealed to now in
America I know we weren't born but we
didn't have any they didn't build any
washing machines and milling new cars
they didn't build anything dryers they
nothing because they spent other time on
the
military
weapons and
so they're run out so we had to wait a
while get Carmen wait a while get up to
market so you read about this wine sauce
resident look in the newspaper two women
asking about it and that were Johanna I
asked him do you think this is true and
he said I don't know why browser will
come all the way in here and rock that
stuff he did that he and see something
that he thought and he had sent deputies
out
and
he was he thought I see so originally he
thought it was proof but he didn't have
any information he was trying to send
the deputies to get some more
information kind of anything but the
first thing he did was all there because
that seems to be important hammock he's
died he's I said why did you call timid
he said because I have an agreement with
them that if any airman is in trouble in
Roswell any kind of problem about any
airplane or flight or anything like that
I call them we don't have room in our
jail for those and that kind of took
care of just to keep them a little while
they just tell them until they stop
there and
like society felt that this had
something to do
sure
that was their business he felt happens
there
what happened that he said he sent the
deputies out and I think I'm of the
opinion that he sent the deputies out
once and that they saw a large black
area blackened area the brights the
Rangeley and that they came back was
dark and then when he when they came
back he had to wait for the next day
that's in the back again to find
something else and when they went back
again
the Army has blocked at home
simple man and I'm talking about on
I just survived it it was called the arm
and see I think Ravel told them how to
get there but didn't but they you know
there's a long distance between nozzle
and Corona
you can't send somebody out of them
search over a large ranch or hook
a
I don't know what time they live that
takes time
so the deputies were turned away by the
Army Air Force yes and then I think it
was then the next day that they are me
in force all came to the office and my
sister what happened when you got to
cross office listed we come here now we
had a small child and Raul is the
shopping place for us to come
one sweet and when we arrived why I
noticed that there were Jeeps
some people you know from our Air Force
there and of course I went right in with
my small child and my husband Jay went
into the office and he said to my father
what's going on George and he said well
we've had a man come in saying that
there is a flying saucer and bringing
the PISA thankin said I don't know what
it is and said we were investigating him
and he said what was it and he said well
it looked like a burnt grass but grass
out there and my husband came back into
the office coming back into the kitchen
my mother prepared the meals the
prisoners and we were in
and we've been discussing or anything
and as the years went along leather
would say Oh remember the time and had
the Flying Saucer in roseville and
papers were out and where I live I'm
very isolated I don't I go 20 miles from
I'm a on one way and clean my back so
I'm not the custom to get in newspapers
are in office and I have no telephone
and electricity at that time because
we're so worried
so I was another week's evening before I
pop it went back to town and knew
anything too particular about it because
I could stay all night and turn around
we have to get home to at night so I
really was not as familiar with it as
Phyllis because she was saying all night
there because she was at was going to
school up in Las Vegas but as the years
went along mother would always say and I
also know of an article that she wrote
that said we do not as to this day know
that there whether it was a flying
saucer what because they told my husband
mr. Wilcox's she would say no what you
say a word so he didn't and he was very
calm about honey he just didn't say
anything who told her Thompson the Air
Force when they came and picked up the
piece or whatever they did she said they
recommended him that's what the words
were in
I had it because she wrote a great deal
and she wrote an article on there four
years at the county jail they were not
in the county jail but that's what she
said four years in the county jail but
they were there as working people in the
jail so on the very back page of her
article she wrote the day the flying
saucer was in Mossel New Mexico remember
what that day when she said that they
thought the date was not on the paper
that's the reason I don't and she said
in nineteen on the outside of this
article that I sent this article to the
Reader's Digest in 1980 see she had
talked it over if she had a whole bunch
of the typhoon Thanks and but they did
not accept it
that was written on the outside she also
said that she I don't know if she took
the article or she spoke to the
Historical Society and Marvel it said
his brasil' Historical Society
make it go on in 1980 so she might've
taken article over - I do not
did your father describe to either
review what this material that Mack
Brazell brought it looked like not to me
he said he brought some material a theme
and a jump like I don't know what it is
that if I can do about what his worth
and about the Air Force warning that
also my mother had written on there this
is a real and true story
and oh she had spoken about it some
after you know that and I think and she
had talked to different members of the
family that there was a passion that
were advised in but that they could not
say
she gave my daughter she had tow and I
think maybe I had one conversation about
it but I can't
we're calling it well enough
that she talked about bodies yes that
she heard that there were bodies
recovered yeah what about Mack
brazilwood happened to him during this
period of time
well the Air Force took him right away
and
and you really never came back to the
sheriff's office and the material was
left there and the airport picked it up
and took it away and death and
and that that was the end of it and my
father said I said how funny you tell
the people on the phone he said I don't
have any information I have to tell them
I don't know that it is God I really
know what I haven't seen it yet in their
forces in like if I'm referring calls to
mere electronics I didn't even answer
I'll think of it according to some
witnesses
he said that he had calls from all over
from England Germany I believe I can't
imagine she wrote it in this article the
names a place where they had the calls
from that morning when we got to town it
was quite exciting rushing around there
a little bit but we just didn't go itís
been going office I just stay back in
the kitchen with mother and then she
told us what my father said but she said
that he was not to say one word and she
didn't say anything either for years and
years the wealthy in his four years in
the Congo so she had to write this
article after 1951 so since she usually
wrote things down sometimes very soon
after they happen yes your honor
gasping it's them
55 in sugar we don't have any I don't
have any date any fruit what guessed it
like fifties to myself that's just what
we had talked about guessing it to be
like fifties early forties so well see
you see this happening story said I'm
ultra and then they were still in the
sheriff's office until I believe it was
49 and may have been a little pay so
we're just daddy some years under that
I'm saying that at the title of the
article his four years the kind of jail
so they had the average the only
question when did your mother write the
article when a sensitive half well I
don't have and we're going to say who
think that it was in the city's we think
it wasn't my father became very ill by
after he came out the sheriff's office
and she was traveling around
the best doctors and everything in the
world to help him and they was very very
busy and she had not started a business
or had anything you know because she had
just come out of this job and he didn't
have a job so then she became a real
estate agent and she did the work and
her father had passed on and
I 64
here boy silly 8:58 no it was a 60 we
decided i think i xt k with now they're
pretty close
what did you all hear about my brazil's
being detained by the army air force I
did hear Phillips did you well I don't
know when I heard it I'm I know he was
behind by the Army Air Force and I know
he's out there but after all you know he
had just been through of this business
here plus we have been interviewed
before plus I ripped the Rose Lynn
Samantha ante 12 missus Stan Freeman
talk okay so I have yeah the last few
years
well I'm absolutely sure what you do
when you do it that's true I don't know
what I do about wrassle until after I
read the book and after
but Allah and I they night after my
father he said I don't know why I browse
the would have brought that stuff in and
some way he indicated that he trusted
Brad and
probably because he was New Mexico ranch
came all the way trying to tell somebody
you know I found something unusual
and so I think I did get that impression
yeah I know I did but when what I
outside know about pretzels in turn I
know
would your father known a weather
balloon if that's what it was
oh I think so on our ranch up there
little square boxes and you can know the
balloon just dissipates it's just and
you pick them up
there's been a number I mean they have a
place that you couldn't send them back
pack air force but Rob said now as far
as he was concerned from what you know
that this was not a weather balloon oh
no I don't think they said it was so now
I brought a piece of a saucer and a
piece of metal or whatever or whatever
mental Internet office in the small
office over there but the door was shut
nobody went in there this long and the
air force picked it up and for the
father's office yes and took it and said
don't you say another word about this
they had a little meeting in there
and all the juice in it like they said
it was probably three people but see I
don't know I didn't doubt you saw the
military you know how Jeep drives up in
front if you have something there were
open jeeps and it was hot weather and
they just they're too busy got out at
him in the office and that's all the
same besides that I did not go in there
unless it wasn't busy you know I didn't
go that's what that unless under
anything there was not my business
do you not husband went in there visited
all the time because he was a man yeah
and it wouldn't go in
after Animalia - I'm sure but I just did
you know I went home Lee my name is by
cellphone when I really did your father
ever name any of the military people who
were involved with taking this material
on his office
what happened after the airport said
this was a weather balloon as far as the
calls well then they just went down
because it
the airport says it's a middle
with the blood of people interesting so
that's a strong faith it was xf8 they
are new they may have known in war aunt
died I remember distinctly thinking that
there's a bright guy don't believe this
but you know you're busy alive and
playing people I didn't dream I've never
had an idea about investigating God
doesn't sound like your mother was
convinced now she was not no I think she
knew very very brilliant and she was she
had she didn't have all of the
responsibilities my father had was all
the prisoners all the deputies in all of
the jail and all fans of she began to be
real curious but she said her he told
her the story and then she kept it this
way she possibly could and then she
thought well she could tell our children
because there it would be her
grandchildren I guess talk to them and
you know kind of come forth but you
can't if they say don't say anything and
you're live right general
and it was very important to rob look at
that right there
important and they were in the public
eye you conformed to thank it's not that
you're putting prisoner your bad but
it's just a part of nature that you fans
like of you not to do something and you
see we do what we can for being you just
do that but they thought seemed
important and a lot of people felt that
the Air Force was doing experiments and
that this was some new experience that
they were doing and that it would be
harmful to their new experiments and you
told what they were some other country
might get the plans you know or some
kind of thing like that but if they were
doing experiments with things and I
think that I thought that that was a
parlor also fetch erotic everybody was
doing their job and they would not tell
anything because a war is a war you know
and you believe that you should be very
figuring on both our husbands were in
the service
funny to have them be enough combat he
thought telling around Roswell today yes
what what would you say is the sense of
a community they are about now 43 years
later Carly here from a lot of people
asked me about and a couple of my
friends bought me the wrong plane
and I have several people and that is
stopping asking questions
and
I have a cup of one woman's two sons
that live in California but they're very
interested in this and I think their
marriage once in a while when they
compensated mother and they told me that
one of them told me that he thought they
were billing some material that was
material that they found that they found
rustles match
have almost duplicated that in this one
can we talk about this I thought that it
was simple people
and they believe it in mother working
base at the time and she just says I
believe it believe what that there was a
flying saucer
and that yeah there because she called
it a flying saucer and wrote about it so
I did they light it as she's a little
older she said I believe she works
advice at the time everything but she
lives in a rest home and also that she's
if we were to take an opinion poll it
Roswell that community what do you think
and the question was do you believe a
flying saucer crashed here in 1947
what would be the results of that poll I
think that would be at least I think at
least had them but now see that's the
old timers too we have a lot of millions
of new people they're posted when we're
talking about Roswell in 1947 we think
Lisbon I think about 15,000 probably
what was announced 40 if they're a
veteran on the Air Force and retired
there they liked it so well I had
friends who had gone to Germany and
lieutenant Compton came back to Russell
and retired these lots of people retired
they're not Navy like we are so now we
have to take those into consideration I
mean if you're talking about the
majority of them that live there right
now but the people who live there then
okay like that it's like most of them
matter I think that it takes two percent
I have when I got here I arrived and I
there was a friend of mine who had a
daughter who's just moved up here so I
gave her a call and I said Alison here's
nowhere you doing up here I said well I
came to kind of a convention for UFOs or
Phibes officers just in that
conversation that was something at
gospel and she said I remember about
that one and I I haven't seen she is uh
she's been in Saudi Arabia she's been in
Sweden she's been all over and she's
with all in business and they had moved
up here and I said go figure calm so to
me I said it to her she had heard of it
because her mother father probably told
her because she probably is in her
forties so she he would be telling that
her mother would have to tell that about
the flying saucer over Basel and she
they lived about 20 miles from me
that's neighbors disclosure to mine yet
other uses have a bookmark to take so I
got you good thank you
kaleriya project I just like to ask you
if you would mind
we know from signing the school
yeah but then you come in with your
question step okay well I just get you
started just asking what you were doing
in 1947 now that
okay I'm ready okay do you have any
introduction
nope no introduction at all we're just
rolling the tape and I just like to ask
you what you were doing in 1947
in 1947 I was at the air base in Roswell
I was in the military and I was first
lieutenant at the time my assignments
were three interestingly enough I was
assistant flying Safety Officer it was a
system based operations officer and I
was assistant group operations officer
now the group was 5/9 bomber and
because of the building I worked in all
three offices that I just told you about
word contained in the same building and
for a time it seems I was running back
and forth at that time I was primarily
in group operations and
the call came in one day to arrange to
help b-29 ready to go as soon as
possible
and of course someone asked where to as
it just in crew onboard and have the
airplane standby and remember Fort Worth
helps turn Blanchard's directive so I
was out in the Operations Office have to
explain you the building is an h-shaped
building and the vertical part of the H
is where the two hallways were wanted
each sign but the one on the right side
ran directly from the parking area out
front straight through the building out
to the ramp the aircraft the cross of
the H half of it was the Operations base
operations office where base pilots came
in fill out their flight plan and step
to one side and obtained their weather
briefing red notices to Airmen and got
all the material ready to go the flight
clearance then was taken and submitted
to the tower to let them know
something's going to happen and two air
traffic control and so as I explained
last night trying or yesterday afternoon
trying to clarify a point each squadron
also have their own operations set up
and they could release their aircraft
without going through base operations
they would let us know a group of taking
off just how many airplanes at work but
they had already handled all their
arrangement from their traffic control
with the tolerance
they rate I was in that operations
office
Colonel Blanchard drove up and came in
and asked his aircraft ready and I am
one of the fellow there who know dead
said yes it's sitting around front ready
to go with this heat turn step out it
back into the hallway and waved to some
people outdoors and still sitting in
your knees and I suspect trying to
recall them another four or five or six
people and I'll say I'll say five
doesn't really matter but they came in
the front door straight down the hallway
and ran out onto the ramp to climb into
the airport these were the people who
were carrying parts of the crashed
flying saucer at that time UFO today
that I got to see that was the only
thing I got to see and very short very
quick
Colonel Blanchard in order to get out of
their way had backed into the doorway of
the cop's office and I stepped up to him
I said Colonel turn sideways I want to
see two
maybe if I hadn't said that to him made
it obvious that I was there I would not
have been shipped out to we clear who
was this immediate response to your
request well he just turned him if your
new Colonel Blanchard and he when he
went on become three-star general vice
chief of staff he was a very commanding
presence and he was a human officer real
leader when he said he wanted something
people said yes sir and and it wasn't
just because if he was the military
so he just turned and looked at me and
he did turn sideways so that I could
half step into the doorway and watch if
I was go through and what I the sigh saw
them carrying certain pieces of these
metals items and as I've described
people when asked the
they had one piece that was like say 18
with 24 inch or coffee table top sides
brushed stainless steel
maybe if you think of the common room
foil roll today when you've pulled out
one side real reflective but that's not
what it was it was the light the
opposite side which is rather dull
doesn't have great reflected and
I've heard it mentioned for so many
times about the i-beam with the markings
on is over I actually saw that piece of
i-beam being carried through and saw the
markings but it was a case of here it
wasn't in there went very quick that was
long I got to see
then when I was gone board the aircraft
went to Fort Worth and major Marcel
I mentioned the operational setup this
had become clear and discussion that
there was some confusion about what
airplane went we're one of the first
interviews I did I they asked me about a
b-29 listen all those was a there was a
b25 also a couple days later we have
occasion so for b25 takes do something
and take something to Fort Worth
then there was a third flight and this
was the b-29 that happy Henderson was
the pilot and he flew to
wright-patterson Field in Dayton Ohio
directly from Roswell yeah now stop off
no I say that not really knowing that
answer but going back to the time on
involved ever I sense the other day if
everyone got the impression that major
Marcel went out to the crash site picked
up this material brought it on base
showed up to the colonel and was flown
out and at the same time Walter Haught
had made this paper with newspaper
released public relations release and
within 12 hours it was all squashed
killed
and every I I picked up that everyone
was thinking that everything went out on
that flight they went for it worth and
then they went on to right past
I have to jump now 40 years feel free
because something that happened in our
house this was a couple we had in for
dinner
and I knew he was a mortician retirement
on the 40th anniversary the local paper
in Roswell reprinted the story of the
flying saucer and the pictures or the
sketches and then they had couple
sketches of what the aliens were
supposed to look like these alien bodies
was acclaimed to find
as we were walking to the front door
down our hallway this all turned to me
and said did you see yesterday's paper
nice and the article on the roselyn's
suggests I did and shocked number one
comes when he said that's what they
looked like
thus we start to talk a little bit I
come to find out and he has since been
interviewed by Stampin freedom he was
the mortician on duty that received a
phone call from the airbase asking for
child sized caskets and Bibles that
night
or say the night after the first
airplane fuel of
it develops that this individual
was driving an ambulance for mortuary
which was a service they provided the
air force and he had going to pick up us
a sick airman in town and took them to
the base hospital now this is the next
night 24 hours later
and
he's an album and see my girlfriend and
it happens that the nurse who handled
the bodies was his was his girlfriend
they'd even been thinking about getting
married
I don't recall her last year first hand
of Naomi
he walked into her lab area and was
immediately stopped by air police and
escorted out before he was actually
taken out she looked up and said I will
call you later
because I said where you gonna go soon
real lieutenant on out they took him out
later they did meet as he told me and
she sketched prescription pad what these
aliens look like
and he had that
sketch and took it back to the mortuary
and put it in a file in the drawer of
his desk where he had a series of files
the work that he had with all the
records they were keeping he delivered
so many caskets already picked up so
many Airmen and took them to the
hospital
Stanton Friedman interviewed this
individual and they arranged to go to
the file building that the mortuary
still maintains and they found all of
the files manila folders and so forth
but he had had in his desk during the
years he worked there except that one
file with the sketches in it and any
remarks that had been picked up sometime
and taken by whom they don't
here again the secrecy veil had come
down
they say we worship that shortly after
this happened now
as I explained yesterday to people to
clarify this point of the different
flights
I sent had learned of course the
sergeant of the guard with a series of
Airmen went out they surrounded the site
manned they swept the area and picked up
everything they could the bodies were
brought in and everything was laid out
hangar 84 and what happened to them well
as I was relating to the fellows the Air
Force had established a system of there
was a base operation of office for all
normal activity and they controlled the
weather station they controlled the
crash equipment the tower operation that
oversaw controlled the immediate area
each squadron had its own contact and
home operations and they could set up
their own training flights establish
their own contact with air traffic
control tell the tower that they were
going to take off tomorrow
twelve airplanes or however many and all
they provided to the base was the fact
that 12 are playing maybe tomorrow man
be gone
let's say a 15-hour mission that's all
we needed to know speaking in terms of
representing the three pops in the
baselines and one of the squadrons this
is about three days later down four days
announcer a training flight and their
aircraft all took off let's say this
point in the order that was prescribed
in super one of those aircraft was flown
by Pappy Henderson which had been loaded
with all material of hangar 84 and what
to write past including bodies yes the
caskets that friend of mine had supplied
from the mortuary
did you see the caskets or the body no I
didn't how do you know that they were on
that boat because that's when they got
there how do I know I was told that's
what happy Henderson said he carried he
was in the hangar and saw this material
and saw the PFAs aircraft afloat
that's years before he mentioned
anything day but at any rate
in other words what I'm trying to convey
is everything did not go out with that
first airplane and when the next flights
went we can't find out today there's no
way of tying it down they have an idea
when he arrived
but that's not important point is that
once the secrecy veil dropped and
current wagered was informed and he
informed his staff they later the
official story is this was a weather
balloon and that's it nothing further
than me who said I ran into
I don't follow misunderstanding the lack
of understanding and the parts of a
couple investigative reporters who asked
me a leading question and I turned and
looked at them AHA like I'm looking into
I said how old are you
they didn't rather startled you're
always and when were you born
well he was born around the time of the
Korean War 50 or - 51 53 you know
different dates for different people
that's all right
I said your knowledge of war has been
limited to the Vietnam situation and the
confusion that was going on and the lack
of support by people for the for that
war and and really the confused way it
was run by Washington authorities I said
never before in the history of military
operations has a national capital set
back and told the people how many bombs
they can drop tomorrow or how many
shells they can fire in our doing this
is a ridiculous way to run an operation
but back in Oh question had evolve
because of all the heart and myself who
knew each other at the airbase New Hope
who year-and-a-half later two years
later shared an office for a year in
town has civilians he were running his
thing I was growing my little operation
and we cut expenses by sharing office
and he had raised the question with
Walter and then with me how come you
fellas never talked to each other and
Walter had made the remark well I guess
I know what I know and he knows what he
knows and that was it well how come you
didn't talk to each other that's what
I'm leading and why I asked him how old
he was in World War two
if you didn't experience it it's very
difficult to understand but listen
someone came up and slapped the
collective nose of the country we fought
back and it was in the newspapers it was
in magazines it was on the radio
statements similar to the loose lips
sink ships or don't talk about anything
don't bet on you know anything because
someone's going to take the information
and use it to your detriment
I said college campuses got into it but
not by using signs that said minefield
don't walk here rather than keep off the
grass
new decedent Aryans and they'd have it
broked off and say minefield don't stop
here
consequently the the entire country
became in a sense brainwashed everyone
was concerned with World War two when I
asked the question did you realize ever
did you ever know that everyone on the
coastline had blackout curtains on their
windows and on their doors when someone
rang the doorbell it turned out the
lights for they opened the door he said
no this is true all the way down the
eastern coast around Florida and the
Gulf of Mexico theory being we shouldn't
allow the enemy to know where our cities
were of course now they could sit out
there during the day and watch and
people in New Jersey could look out of
the ocean and see tankers being blown up
by torpedoes this was taking place right
out there and this is the way we
operated if you were told not to talk
about anything and then if you were in
the military it was even more emphasized
consequently
Walter knew his his thing I knew my
thing and we never talked about we had
never talked to one another about the
Roswell incident until after we were
invited to come here and suddenly we
both thought what do you think I guess
we both felt we had to explain to each
other what we did know what do you think
happened but crashed
I think some type of craft of which we
were not at all familiar had a problem
and did come apart and crashed in the
desert area New Mexico I really do as
the properties of the material that was
found was unknown to all our scientists
the bodies have never been no one had
ever been seen like that before these
sketches were true and I feel they were
you knew this mortician pretty well yes
it developed that he in my life what
school together and his wife and I knew
each other through some friends from the
moment I first went to Roswell 1945 to
learn 5a 29 and we're very close friends
and came close to marrying one another
you know and she as much as told that to
my wife just but you got there first -
my wife Joanne and we've been close
friends ever since
though all those times ever since the
event took place we knew each other and
we never talked what happened to her
the nurse I heard conflicting stories
I'll jump back to the time of just after
the incident occurred the airplanes have
taken the parts and by
I was shipped out to the Filipinos I
said after two weeks person within two
week was that was that unexpected well
it developed it was unexpected these
things occurred often on people but
there was a telegram twx called number
came in from 8th Air Force had said
urgent need one each flying Safety
Officer MOS number such-and-such report
to Clark Field and Philippines
and they turn around look well I'm not
even sure what might have had my name
out because I was the only weights and
balance officer on that base and
so I was shipped out going to Clark
field and Philippines because of being
weights and balances I understand
the nurse was shipped out the same week
a sergeant with regard and guards all
who surrounded the site swept the area
and picked pieces up they were all
shipped on every one of us went to a
different bait someplace around the road
so that no two of us were together
that by design demon
oh yes I believe it was by design
because it takes it it's been looking
back through the years and even at that
time I suspected something because I got
Clarkfield and they didn't need weights
and balance I said they had never asked
for
I said well that's what this telegram
says and they said we don't care what
that says we we don't need one we've got
one and we don't need another one they
said what else do you do nice said what
operations office is it alright assigned
you to squadron so-and-so as the
operation box that's where I went and
we were involved in for high altitude
for Riga that's why I spent the time
when we're doing taking pictures from
high altitude
where was the nurse [ __ ] empty I
understand she was shipped to Germany
and I understand it was told that there
was an airplane crash and she and her
nurses were all killed
the sergeant of the guards that
surrounded the territory and picked up
the material he lives in New Mexico and
I understand
just recently spoke to one of the
reporters for the first time but his
information has not been released in any
of the stories I say that because the
investigative reporter said Bob you just
saw him and he had spoken to us and for
the first time since the event that was
well that was nearly 43 years exactly
you know and he's been weird since were
the first ones he's talked about he said
we're not going to use any of his
material at this point because we have
to dovetail and collaborate make sure
place that I am finding that what you
said time speaking these is what you
have told us this evening just
emphasizes and proves the point what
everyone else has said
this particular reporter by the way with
come out of New York City and he said
when he got the assignment he was
totally aghast they would think sending
him out to research some unidentified
flying object which he didn't believe
but he said I become convinced of being
here so roughly speaking that's my story
I saw a couple things I'm involved with
scheduling the aircraft I was shipped
out with several other people all at the
same time and 40 years went by before a
best friend of mine spoke up for the
first time I know something about that
since that time Stanton Friedman has
interviewed the individual I took them
took Stanton up in the mountains to meet
the man because Stanton didn't know
whether he should go this was rather
interesting as an aside perhaps had
nothing to do with the interview but I
was talking in the Stanton and his hotel
room in Roswell in stances well
someone's always invited me up there for
dinner tomorrow
do you suppose my article it was kind of
like a route car and drive up there if
you think it'd be worthwhile and I
should stand knowing this individual
he's one of the good old boys he speaks
his piece if he invited you to come up
we have dinner with him that means he
wants you to come up and have dinner
with the fender
there wasn't a polite thing he was doing
and says an exceptional thing he's doing
while at home cleared the decks with my
wife and calls stand back and said I'll
take you up there tomorrow help you and
I'll introduce you so we did they have a
great interview and then we all went in
to have dinner together we continued the
interview clarifying some points for
Stanton since you and the Morticia both
had interested in the relationship with
male
the nurse come I have to ask what you
think
what you were told about having been
killed and plane accident
well I accept that my only thought was I
had two thoughts about it
one is gosh what a waste because when I
was working in there with in group
operations the colonel who sat in front
of me regarde say the colonel Operations
Officer behind whom I sat with my desk
and to my left was measure Woody's Wonka
who flew the bikini dropped
and Colonel got an assignment to go
overseas
and his airplane was reportedly blown up
over the ocean
he had nothing to do with the Roswell
incident because he was going overseas
before the roselyn's that took place and
all those things the falls are here
today and gosh Fred you're going where
tomorrow what was that right you know
your airplane goes down your losses
another friend died and that's what he
thought the second thing I thought of in
regards to Naomi and the nurses was of
course now I'm overseas and learned this
either while I was there right after I
got back but her plan had been lost so
there's two possibilities one was the
normal natural thing of somehow an
airplane being lost because it does
occur or boy is the government taken
that extreme control what she knows
because she was the one who actually
worked on the bodies but another thing
was that they had called this mortician
asking him for
the information on taking care of the
bodies because he had just newly
returned from this school the latest
methods known at that time how to
preserve the vices she had related to
her what he knew she was trying to do
that
[ __ ] more first-hand information about
the alien body from any of us
what about yourself do you have any
concern former military man are you for
attention
no so this does not any direct hold the
government has over the terms of tip did
you sign any kind of secrecy oh no I was
not told to keep quiet
some people were who may felt had more
information than they knew I did and
it's just as I learned there anyone will
shift up so that probably pretty much
took care of it and that was the first
mission of this mortician for example
because of his involvement
he was visiting his mother and father
were visited by military people whether
they were in uniform or in civilian
dresses and they were warned not to say
anything to anybody about anything very
direct and once again if I believe this
man without faith
and so some people were directly told
others were just shipped out I came back
from overseas to earn water pot had had
resigned his commission
lest they left him Walter of course as
you probably know never did see any he
personally never saw any of the parts or
pieces or whatever he just happens to be
the guy that wrote the release it
stirred everything yeah and again it was
on Thank You mr. Sharkey I appreciate
your time so that's all I know
fascinating
I still get tongue-tied and forget
things questions that I've answered 15
20 times same question but just a little
bit differently shake your heads back
off and regroup well but I can only give
you my standard lecture about what
should be relaxed it's just you and me
talking just sort of ignore Tom this
camera just pretend they're not here
eating's want you to be as comfortable
as possible I do have a bad habit and
you may think I'm looking over the
camera I'll do that occasionally you
know when I'm trying to think I may lose
eye contact with you and that was just
strictly I want to break I may just
sense it could excuse him the way second
stoppers kept the second okay Tom we
rollin yes we aren't all right
mr. Hart can you tell me about the day
that Colonel Blanchard gave you a call
told me to put out a news release what
was happening that day you and he
recalled my phone conversations
basically up until the time I got the
phone call from I sure can't tell you
what was happening it was probably a
very routine day I was doing either some
funk relations work base housing or
something else I really I can't remember
what it wasn't just the normal working
got the telephone call from Colonel
Blanchard and in essence he told me that
we had he had in his possession a flying
saucer parts thereof give me a little
bit of idea where it came from
he ranch north west of Roswell then
stated that major Marcel just in
ourselves our base intelligence officer
was going to fly it to Fort Worth
terminal
or to General Roger Ramey who is
commander commanding general only eight
their force at that time
and what a kernel question want you to
do a tell me they're preparing a release
but basically the information that he
gave me over the phone when it was dumb
to take it into community and deliver
and deliver it to the for news media we
had in Roswell at that time which is
what I did especially recall would that
have happened the initial phone
conversation during the morning or in
the afternoon to the best of my
remembrance it would have been in the
morning and I would have to guess
somewhere I would guess around 9:00
o'clock the only reason I come up with
that figure is that had to be done and
gotten into town so that it would have
gone to the record
and time for them to set it and to have
gone ahead and running in that day's
evening paper and wood you know what
they this happened I would say they ate
through July 1947 and that was the days
of the Roswell de américas article what
once you wrote up the deuce release then
what happened after that as I said I had
to take it into town he told me to take
it in so that if there was any validity
to the fact that this was a flying
saucer that and information got out to
other news media other than our own
he felt that he wanted our people there
in Roswell who had first crack in it
didn't what then feel that he had given
the information out to someone who got
it to the press services outside of
Roswell so I took it in town and
delivered it to the fourth news
in town two radio stations and to those
papers you haven't recalled of your
itinerary was who you went to first for
example I'm almost certain I went to the
radio station kg FL first secondly 2k
SWS they were a half a block north and
then I took it to the Daily Record which
was a block further in north and then on
my way back out to the base I dropped it
off at the morning dispatch about three
blocks from the Daily Record what what's
recollection about the reception
initially when you handed out this news
release a tease various local outlets
did anybody read this material respond
immediately
I don't believe they did I believe again
you're going back to many many years I
believe first place I went was to set
the kgf del and I believe I just simply
left it on the desk of the receptionist
that's I recall she was not there and I
Frank Joyce to fester my memory was in
the studio and he could see the
reception area and also see out on the
street I think I probably pointed at it
indicate that it was something for them
I don't remember what had happened at
Kay SWS the record I gave it to the
editor because he sat close to the front
door
how's that I don't how are you that
might like to have this or go free
nothing fantastic just the normal
routine what I did when I brought only
news releases then I went down to the
dispatch again I believe there I took
him to either the characters office or
the publishers office Island
okay to not stick my head in
should degree with the publisher on the
actual
delivering of it to who I gave it as I
may have seen a half dozen people in the
different
those media offices and
who I
finally so here it is it's kind of hard
to differentiate from one to the other
nothing river work nothing nobody said
Wow
you don't just but then most put it
talented when most a journalist
treatments releases that's right in this
was not something that was unusual
because you walk into someone's office
and say here's a news release which I've
done many many times and nothing was
that hot that they had to grab it and
run back and stop presses and that type
of thing so they just a matter of just
they took it in probably glanced at it
and had a few words and I went my merry
way and what happened next after you
completed your appointed rounds I
returned to the base when I got into my
office phones ringing I picked it up and
the first call was from London England
and through the format I find out
lose man over there his question was how
did major Marcel know how to fly the
subject I had enrollees and stated that
major Marcel had flown the object to
forward meaning that he had put it on an
aeroplane of God in a flew the aeroplane
or choice of words and they had quitted
there are tremendous a number of calls
of the same effect if this is an
unidentified flying object how would we
have someone within our air force that
knew how to just get in there and flip
switches and controls sell them all some
were ever terse is another one of those
fly-by-night stories can you verify it
commanding officer
one that stated this is what we had
my certification but for you for me that
was more than enough verification when
he said something that was the law that
went on continually we had continual
phone calls people
let some around five o'clock Wednesday
to six o'clock resort I left there I
would guess 7:30 8 o'clock and that time
it tapered off completely
the last half-hour soldiers looking over
what had happened during the course of
the day and beyond the Roswell incident
the base didn't stop operating because
we found that so-called flying saucer
what happened the next step as you
recall the only thing that happened of
any import as far as I was concerned I
believe I read it in the morning
newspaper heard on the news that general
Ramey said that we didn't have a flying
saucer that that was a weather balloon
with which I just read this tremendous
sigh of relief and I think I turned to
one of the people in the office and said
have they sure made fools of us ish many
and we fit in the category of hundreds
of others that had said they saw flying
objects it was not uncommon of people to
think they had a flying object and owned
the home
it shot down
beyond that that was the end of it did
you see Aryans wreckage or any of the
material none whatsoever
do you believe the criminal Blanchard
had seen it yes I do and why do you feel
that way I don't think he would have
been so
I don't want to say gung-ho but I don't
think he would have been so confident in
his comment we have a flying saucer in
our possession parts of a flying saucer
I don't
exactly he wasn't overly excited he
wasn't flipping about it there was a
normal routine type of conversation that
we've haven't he called me and said he
wants this done but he sounded pretty
positive about he sounded positive yes
that would he have would you have any
reason to believe the criminal answered
mistaken this material for being any
form of weather balloon or observation
device I don't think there's a one
chance in a billion that he would not
have recognized
he was not a West Point graduate class
of thirty seventh best I recall had gone
up to second lieutenant to Colonel not
too many years very intelligent
individual not the type to just jump off
on tangents I think he knew a weather
balloon if he had season that would have
been the end of that he wouldn't have
gone anywhere
he told major Marcel this is a weather
balloon
then again made of ourselves with an
automatic
that was my next question is it possible
to mark major Marcel would have been
this way in Ellis is it possible that
major Colonel Blanchard might have been
misinformed by somebody who told them
about told him about what this wreckage
was without having seen it for himself I
would doubt that very much
I don't think he would have taken the
actions he did by taking going down to
operations with it if he was there in
the operations building he certainly saw
I'm sure that major Marcel had talked to
him and had him some appreciate advices
far as he was concerned that word view
that
how much just Marcel knew about it again
very intelligent individual
and not the type that would just jump at
anything and try to carry it to an end
between the tool I'm certainly one or
the other would have called the other
ones hand if it was a weather balloon so
what did you think when general Ramey
said it was a weather boy believe that
we're in 1947 when the general said it
was a weather balloon it was a weather
girl and was a load off of our mind as
far as I was concerned I said are mine
my office population zone so you don't
want to be focused we want attention out
of it completely you're just as happy
that there was the kid very much so
that was as far as I was concerned that
was the end of the story surprisingly I
used to say general that time at the
felon general
Blanchard come in town he called me back
wanna have breakfast with him her lunch
never or was mentioned
conversations was that deliberate on
your part oh I had very frankly
completely forgotten about it
and whether hated forgotten I would
doubt it very much that he just never
brought it up
did anything happen did the colonel say
anything about this incident shortly
after general Rama's statement perhaps
him a staff meeting in the next staff
meeting it was a lot a week later I
think we held that kind of every Monday
he made some comments about our agenda
I believe after those comments he paid
some statement
to the fact we sure messed up on that
one
last week matter of fact he said that
outfit that was letting sending those
weather balloons were here on our
station they were from white sands and
they were
checking the upper atmosphere winds from
east to west
he sort of helped a buttress the weather
poles were hearing he would that comment
we all see we knew it along you know we
were always real smart all this up we
knew that it wasn't a flying saucer
did you ever have a chance to talk with
the Jesse Marcel not until about 1980
next time I talk to
as he came to Roswell with Johnny and
from a TV station in New Orleans he was
taking a man out to the site to show
where it had happened
the interview myself had brought Jesse
will
they're talking about it
that ties it that was no weather balloon
what I brought into the general's office
is not what was there when I came back
in
or there
I kind of convinced me who's a neighbor
of mine locked down the street in
Roswell
I forgot
very fine individual priceless some dr.
Marcel
it was quite a sharp little
cracker at the gate still is what about
another officer there on the basin who
worked with
major Marcel shirt Cabot does that mean
wear the belt with you
the name yes I've heard it he was OSI or
CIA or something I had no association
whatsoever at any time
had you asked this question in 1947 and
he walked by it and I could have said
that's him over there had been about the
extent of it had nothing to do with
anyway matter shaker
there been some talk about the
circumstances under which you left the
Air Force suggestion was that somehow
you were pressured into into leaving
because of your involvement in the story
that sort of set it straight you want a
long story very short story let's try
the short version I could ask ah
at the time of the incident we had a two
month old daughter build a house a
couple months before I was gone a lot of
the time I had about four different jobs
we were starting to wonder well I think
my daughter her age of two and a half or
three months wondered what this was that
came in the house every once in a while
my wife and I talked about it and talked
about it what decision force two main
try to decide
stainless service or get out we kicked
this thing back and forth and back and
forth and finally in February 1948 we
decided that we'd stay in Roswell I
thought I knew enough people in business
there that active and nothing else I
could get a job in Roswell
I submitted my letter of resignation I
was a bigger Air Force officer put on
are obliged s capabilities to 19 to 48
obviously 18th of 19 and 48 and got a
Twix at the base started out first
lieutenant Walter G hawk serial number 0
41 1 2 3 and goes on and on and on and
on and on and it states that relieved of
all duties and assignments and all that
and hands up mr. Walter G Hart's
permanent dress this 14050 7 Street
Roswell in Mexico I I thought it was
rather humorous I started out as
lieutenant Harte up here and it twits
that long at the bottom I was no longer
I was mr. Hart it had nothing to do
whatsoever with the incident or anything
else that had happened on her inmates
who just a personal manner that my wife
and I both felt we'd like to raise our
daughter in Roswell a small enough
community good school system everything
else maybe we should have been thinking
that far ahead at that point I liked it
was one of the things that we were
taking into account
I was also probably going to be
transferred to Fort Worth within a
matter of
for six months we didn't want to go to
Fort Worth we want to stay in the
smaller community
my teacher had told me that if I did go
forward that I would
Relations Officer 8th Air Force he
transferred over there subsequently and
became operations officer babe Air Force
start going up to a lateral rather
rapidly is rather well connected was yes
is
mentor was
first I have to stop on that I love my
say curse easy LaLanne
curse you lady so as far as you're
concerned you could have saved with
military Andrew another bright future no
talk about your being shipped out after
the none whatsoever
things just went on the way they had
been going on not the day I arrived on
the station but we came back from bikini
Bible night they're attacking
a factor
Roswell might remain
group public relations officer and also
based public relations officer do you
have any regrets having been involved in
this incident
none whatsoever I follow vaccinating I
mean so many different people 99 percent
are real nice but once in a while that
1% always pops up and it squares you
away go on your merry way
it's been fun can your heart of hearts
what do you think it was that was in was
on that ranch forty three years ago
some type of craft from outer space from
where I do not
Oh
I've talked to enough people involved in
it
so Jessie ourselves senior and junior
other people that had a little touch of
it
Bob Shirky still lives in Roswell
everything I've heard from the
investigators always pretend they come
up with something new I and bottom and
really is a surprise that puts another
Krum starting to crown or everyone say
but my feeling is it there's been so
much that has been brought forward by
legitimate people that there had been
something two of them
was something that
crash-landed out there the desert
probably
I get you to express your desire about
what our government should do about this
this point in history
well I very frankly I think that the
government ought to take all files that
they have
on this subject and turn over to a
committee of Jim
you follow just if you commit the use of
that word whether they be ones that I'm
familiar with or a panel of scientists
who are not negative but we'll look at
all the information with an open mind
and come up with a conclusion I think
that
this is censorship
pure and simple I don't like it
watch the right for people to walk the
streets with placards and protests I
wonder what would happen if bunch of
people it's very walking around Pentagon
the archives during science we want the
file I don't think we'd get very far
is there anything that that I've missed
in in all of this that you feel is
important to add to this record that
we're trying to try to put together
experiences the Jumeirah but all my
experiences with us have been extremely
pleasant I met some of the nicest people
I've only had one experience it was a
telephone call from Philip Colin when I
came I was out of time I came home my
wife said the shadow called you might
you know the shadow the squeaking door
start call me he was a friend from my
past his focus
telling me that I was going to be in
trouble I should forget this whole thing
told me all about how the materials were
found and they were put
freight cars and ship from one place to
the next my recollection of that is real
vivid primarily because it was a trying
to talk to this phone keep a straight
face my wife kept walking near me free I
thought that was funny was he told her
when she first talked to him morning
he said something to the effect world
what do you think about
oh I think it's a lot of fun
about it that was really kind of a crank
on father you know this was no I tried
everything I could trick them into give
me some Kluger I know I'm at the place
that I know from where he this good stop
biting kept on not threatening me
warning
the dire consequences if I
talking about
we still laugh about
tourists the people of just everybody's
been extremely gracious they're very
knowledgeable people won some money get
someone who asked a question that kind
of throws you off in the corner but I
try to answer everything as honestly as
I can
and I've had no trouble in anybody I try
to keep my story straight you change
them that I try to keep my story simple
so that it'll be straight and I don't
have to cover anything up that's about
it
enough of that thank you very much merci
you're welcome
okay well let's get back to the meeting
I'll walk you down there Oh before I let
you go